Schumaker just go in everybody good
evening everyone
are you happy that the emergency
evacuation amount and I think just to
remind you if I may you're being
recorded and that switch off your phone
we're so concluding that's right so
first item on the agenda is policies for
absence of anything apologies to members
minutes to the meeting held on the 6th
of February is it when you shop
sometimes is true record very straight
anybody you want to bring anything up
from that it's not that we're on the
agenda that we have in front of us okay
any declarations of interest please
members if anything should arise during
the meeting you realize it it should be
declared please do so and we'll make
sure it's milites right so message refer
to the secretary for Communities there
are none so it goes straight to item six
raises the Chancellor's project program
management office dashboard so item six
to start us off please
Thank You chair the dashboard as you
know is produced on a quarterly basis
right off days all those projects
or links to the MTFs home in this it's
pretty so the two items that are
referred to within that report or the
homelessness project which is
essentially around home sister option
act and success various implementation
measures have in mitigating against that
ongoing risk and the ICT project which
again I think is self-explanatory in
relation to use migration thank you any
questions please here's just one for my
chairman oh I wonder have we any idea
Albany as a hidden households within the
district I know we obviously know that
is it there are others or whatever have
we any idea of those people who are
living at home with parents grandparents
Chairman I believe we have that probably
have that information from the last
census whether there's any any update on
that I think we need to take back and
just have a weakness
Lucas II have to do that I think it's
one of those things if I may you know
you wouldn't necessarily know because
obviously you don't know about every
household where somebody's registered
something or where they've applied for
better housing because they are
overcrowded or whatever reason they
obviously that might be recorded but I
think it's one of those things I mean
they can get in households for a reason
and that's that's part of where we are
but having said that of course we you
know we have got records of those who
have registered with us that's really we
can go on by the moment and I think
you're right as far as the census is
concerned it's very difficult this is
well a tall figure anyway I think
we homicide logs will be lower so it's a
difficult figure to produce but I'm
happy to see how Valusia to determine
whether or not there's any further
information we can provide about it
sometimes called silver surfers as well
and whatever exactly I think the fact
that I've mentioned it enormous with
regard to people requiring large beams
and it has that same impact where
they've got large families who are
living in the same house and they need
to have the most we aren't significant
they are operational
they basically have fulfilled the
original tender that we asked and as you
can see in the report going to say about
some that wealth and to scope some that
we combined together so then maybe some
of those services we have as well
excellent
okay the other thing I wanted to ask you
is our colleagues in South American tour
were completed the technical audit of
the server room and other things as well
and you said that you're waiting for the
report you know I mean they're like a
lot yeah we have asked them for that
report and we're just waiting for them
to send it we have chased now somebody
bit seniors have escalated them and
we've said to them that you know we'll
have the report in any format that they
can give us at this moment in time so
I'm just waiting we'll come back okay
thank you very much indeed any other
questions please members okay so members
except the recommendation is that
confidence will be known so item 7 is
the sort is the chief officer for
conspiracy yeah I understand this is
being held because we're looking for
another service in chairman I have not
and I think we're using pen right wait
for this as well we our Chairman is
remembers any any questions around that
I mean that we need to have it because
that's how forward yeah because it
hadn't met before because there wasn't
any
at the time there were many nights out
thank you
things change as we know that was great
now we go into hopefully into exclusion
to the present public so to agree the
present public be excluded from the
meeting remaining business on the
grounds the exact information is defined
in paragraph three five one
Oh schedule twelve layer the Local
Government Act 1972 would be